bonjour changer de code changer de quoi
de quad vestimentaire de code
alimentaire de co2 secret de code de son
téléphone de code de quoi l'école de
logiciels tellement de codes du corps
social du code de comportement à l'égard
les uns des autres
du code de politesse du code de la route
du quad ça renvoie un ensemble loin
ensemble de règles puisque nous devons
changer l'ensemble des lois et des
règles qui nous gouvernent sans doute
bien des choses doivent être changées
faut-il changer le code génétique
peut-être aussi pour faire en sorte que
nous y allions mieux dans un étang un
être humain un peu plus responsable un
peu plus compassionnel un peu plus
empathique
peut-être faut-il toucher à ça peut-être
ne faut-il pas toucher à ça changer de
code ça renvoie à ce qui doit être avare
y en dans l'homme et ceux qui ne doit
pas l'être
on vous qu'est ce qui doit être un
variant qu'est ce qui doit rester propre
de l'homme
qu'est ce qui choque pas le droit de
toucher quand on regarde l'histoire de
l'humanité on se rend compte que
l'humanité touche à tout y compris à
lui-même et que l'histoire de l'humanité
j'ai essayé de rentrer de livre en livre
c'est une langue traduction de l'être
vivant en un objet un artefact
progressivement nous sommes complété par
des prothèses et puis les prothèses
viennent en nous et nous devenons
progressivement nous mêmes sans nous en
rendre compte vraiment des prothèses
notre code génétique lui-même
progressivement connu et c'est très bien
ainsi progressivement pénétré c'est très
bien ainsi
nous sommes de plus en plus capables de
lutter contre ces défauts et c'est très
bien ainsi nous sommes très capables de
créer des bac 5 qui vont protéger ce
code l'améliorer le défendre contre les
virus et c'est très bien ainsi
et puis où la route
quoi c'est de fabriquer d'une façon
artificielle
à partir de ce code et de tout le reste
de qui forment le ce qui forme la vie
des êtres artificiels
est ce qu'il y aura à jouer le
frontières qu'on mettra pour protéger
l'essentiel de la vie contre
l'artificialisation des codes où
serons-nous un jour dans bien longtemps
par le biais de cette maîtrise des codes
des objets comme les autres qui se
croiront éternelle parce qu'ils ont été
fabriquée artificiellement puisque c'est
dans l'artefact que se situe la vérité
mais peut-être vous voulez vous parler
les codes d'une façon beaucoup plus
prosaïque
est ce qu'il faut le changer le code de
politesse ça se fait tous les jours
est-ce qu'il faut changer nos codes de
alimentaire il faut le faire il faut
manger autrement il faut manger plus
sainement
est ce qu'il faut le changer nos codes
de relation les uns avec les autres
sûrement plus empathique plus doux plus
tolérant plus flux respectueux plus
bienveillants plus altruiste
oui et le code social doit passer d'un
cône de l'égoïsme et de l'avidité un
coup de l'altruisme et du respect
comment le faire est ce que ce sera un
changement brutal est ce que ce sera un
changement volontaire est ce que ce sera
un changement
progressif on y viendra nous passerons
du code de l'égoïsme et de l'avidité au
code de l'altruisme et de l'empathie
ça viendra après un choc sans doute oui
nous appartient nous commencer à le
faire pour ça de prendre conscience que
dans la crise actuelle
tous les codes sont remises en cause
toutes les règles seront mises en cause
et en particulier celle qui détermine la
nature de ce convoi de ce qu'on fait de
ce qu'on pense on pense aujourd'hui à
court terme chacun pour soi il faut
penser à long terme pour les autres et
donc à long terme pour les générations
futures
le vrai code doit être celui qui rend
possible la vie aux générations futures
ça c'est la clé de notre destin nous ne
survivrons pas nous même si nous ne
donnons pas les moyens de vivre aux
générations futures notre vie dépendant
pas de notre passé mais de notre avenir
notre vie ne dépend pas seulement de nos
parents mais ne nous en force et nous ne
créons pas les conditions d'une vie
décente pour les enfants d'une vie vaut
pas moi j'appelle à la création d'une
société positive et à l'adn se situe
positive une économie de la vie c'était
une économie où ne sont véritablement
toléré par tous les codes que les
secteurs qui sont utiles à la vie et pas
les secteurs qui l'empoisonnent ne pas
autoriser le sucre pas utiliser le tabac
ne pas autoriser l'alcool ne pas
autoriser le pétrole ne pas autoriser
tout ce qui découle de ses activités qui
sont une large partie de l'alimentation
une petite partie d'agriculture une
large partie de l'industrie des
transports automobiles aérien chemin de
fer une large partie de l'industrie
mécanique que d'azur chimiques
d'industrie de textile alors qu' il
faudrait développer les économies de la
vie c'est à dire les secteurs de la
santé de l'hygiène l'alimentation de
l'éducation de la culture
du digital numérique de la sécurité
démocratie du logement durable de
l'énergie du rap sion fait tout cela on
recrée un code de la vie autour d'une
économie de la vie au service des
générations futures et on aura réussi
ainsi à créer les conditions de ce monde
qui lui manque tant
je vous souhaite de meilleur